مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
عشيه مثوله امام المحكمه ترامب يشن هدوء
هجوما لاذرعا على الديمقراطيين ويتهم اقصى
اليسار بمحاوله تدمير امريكا
الجيش الاوكراني يوسع رقعه هجومه المضاد
وقائد فاجنر يدعو الدفاع الروسيه للتركيز
على فض الهجوم بدلا من الانشغال بامور
اخرى
[موسيقى]
لا تعمل
الامداد يصل بصعوبه كبيره جدا
الصحه السودانيه تعلن عن صعوبات في ايصال
المساعدات والهلال الاحمر يتحدث عن نقص
حاد في مواد الاغاثه
دفع الف
وتيري الاستهلاك الاخوان السوريين
والاخوان الفلسطينيين اللي مثلنا مثلهم
كلنا اخوه بهذا البلد اليوم لعدم دفعهم
الفواتير وزير الطاقه اللبنانيه يهدد بقطع
الكهرباء عن مخيمات اللاجئين في بلاده
[موسيقى]
غادر الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
نيوجيرس نيوجيرس المتفقا الى فلوريدا
تمهيدا لمثوله لاول مره امام محكمه
فيدراليه في ميامي على خلفيه قضيه وجهت له
فيها 37 تهمه من بينها الاحتفاظ غير
القانوني بمعلومات تتعلق بالامن القومي
وعرقله العداله وشهاده الزور ووجهت لترامب
التهم لانه قام عند مغادره البيت الابيض
بنقل الالاف من الوثائق وبعض هذه الوثائق
السري وكان يجب ان يعهد بها الى الارشيف
الوطني ولانه رفض بعد ذلك اعاده معظمها
رغم طلبات مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي وبحسب
لائحه الاتهام تضمنت الوثائق السريه
معلومات عن القدرات الدفاعيه للولايات
المتحده ودول اجنبيه وحول البرامج النوويه
للولايات المتحده ونقاط الضعف المحتمله في
حال وقوع هجوم على الولايات المتحده وحول
فائحه
هذا وقال الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بانه يامل ان يشاهد الشعب الامريكي
باكمله ما يفعله اقصى اليسار ببلاده وخلال
تصريحات له على منصه
ان الولايات المتحده في حاله تدهور خطير
ومستمر الى جانب اخر اكد الرئيس الامريكي
السابق ان استولت على كوبا وما كان ليحدث
ذلك تحت ادارته على حد تعبيره
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا سانتقل الى مؤتمر صحفي لشرطه
مياميل الحديث عن الاجراءات الامنيه التي
ستتخذها سلطات هناك
عنده وصول الرئيس
وبالتالي نريد ان نتاكد من
المستعدون شكرا وساعطي الكلمه الان
استمعنا جزء من المؤتمر الصحفي والذي على
ما يبدو يعني لا يستعمل الانجليزيه يستعمل
لغه اخرى سانتقل الان الى الزميل بيار
غانم من واشنطن للحديث عن الاجراءات
الامنيه التي ستتخذها طبعا السلطات هناك
فور وصول الرئيس ترامب او قبل حتى وصله
ترامب التحضيرات ابيار التحضيرات الامنيه
لوصول ترامب وما المتوقع بالسعه المقبله
المتوقع اولا هو وصول ترامب الى فلوريدا
وهذا امر تريد الشرطه وقوات الامن ان تحفظ
انه خصوصا ان هناك الكثير من المؤشرات
التي يتحدث عنها رجال الامن من ان مؤيدين
للرئيس السابق من الممكن ان يقوموا
بمظاهرات وربما ايضا باعمال شغب الى حد
كبير جدا الاجراءات سوف تكون مماثله للتي
شهدناها منذ عده اسابيع في مدينه نيويورك
عندما حضر امام المحكمه وربما تكون
الاجراءات الى حد كبير جدا بعيده عن
الاضواء في الداخل ولكن مفتوحه امام
الصحافه في الخارج وما حدث في نيويورك سوف
يتكرر غدا في فلوريدا
عندما يصل الى المحكمه ماذا يعني كيف
سيكون المسار هناك سيستمعون التراب ماذا
سيحصل من بعد هل نتحدث عن محاكمه طويله
ايضا كالمحاكمه السابقه التي ذكرتها
نحن في الخطوات الاولى لهذه المحاكمه غدا
سوف يدخل ترامب الى مبنى المحكمه سوف يتم
تسجيله كشخص وجهت له تهم ليس هناك بالضبط
تاكيد من قبل المحكمه ان كانوا سوف ياخذون
له صوره او بصمات او اشياء غير ذلك خصوصا
انه شخصيه معروفه داخل المحكمه من المنتظر
اولا ان يؤكد انه تسلم هذه التفاصيل ومن
الممكن ايضا ان يلتزم الصمت لو وجهت له
الالتهابات اقول له لو وجهت له هذه
الاتهامات لان هناك بعض الاخبار خلال
الساعات الماضيه التي تقول انه حتى الان
ليس هناك فريق محاماه مكلف من قبل ترامب
امام هذه المحكمه للدفاع عنه او لاتخاذ
الاجراءات ومرافقتها وبالتالي من الممكن
ان تكون الاجراءات غدا برقراطيه فقط من
دون توجيه التهم للتراب ولكن الساعات
المقبله لو اصبح لديه فريق مقبول من قبل
المحكمه ومسجل في ولايه فلوريدا فان
الاجراءات سوف تكون توجيه التهم التزام
الصمت على الارجح وليس ان يقول انه مذنب
او غير مذنب شكرا على كل حال سنبقى نتابع
معك ومع الزملاء مسار وهذه المحاكمه شكرا
لك
مفارقه في محاكمه راب المقبله حيث سيمثل
امام قاضيه كان قد عينها قبل ثلاث سنوات
في عهده غير ان القاضيه كانت المقربه لدى
ترامب حين كان رئيسا خاصه في تقديم
الاستشارات القانونيه فما دورها في جلسه
محاكمه ترامب فلنتابع
عينها قاضيه سابقا ويمثل امامها متهما
القاضيه ايلين كانون عينها ترامب عام 2020
قاضيه في فلوريدا
ما دورها في محاكمه ترامب الاشراف على اول
ظهور له في محكمه ميامي
المسؤوله عن مواعيد الجلسات وسيرها في
قضيه الوثائق السريه
والمعجبه بالترامب سابقا قدمت استشارات
لرئيسها السابق وعبرت عن اعجابها بارائه
القانونيه
ولدت في كولومبيا عملت في سلك القانون عام
ومدعيه عامه فيدراليه عام 2013 واليوم
القاضيه الاكثر جدلا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من كاليفورنيا عبر
زوم الدكتور ريتشارد جرابر خبير في
الحملات الانتخابيه الامريكيه دكتور
ريتشرد يعني محاكمات متتاليه على وقع
حملات انتخابيه او حمله التي قد بداها
ماذا يعني ذلك على مسار الحمله الانتخابيه
خصوصا وانه حتى الساعه يحصد ويملك اكثر من
نصف القاعده الانتخابيه الجمهوريه
نعم
يبدو هو ان هذه المحاكمات لم تؤثر عليها
او تضر
بهذه الاجراءات القانونيه ضدك ويبدو ان
شعبيته تزداد
ولكن هذا على المدى القصير اما على المدى
البعيد فسيكون الامر صعبا حيث الناخبه
الامريكي بعد ان يرى مدى جديه هذه
الاتهامات
والتي وربما
ربما يبتعدون عنه لاختيار مرشحه جمهوريه
اخر هذا ممكن ولكن في هذه اللحظه هذه
الاجراءات لم تؤثر عليه ابدا
نتحدث عن محاكمه امام قادن يعتبر محايد
نوعا ما وهو وجه اتهامات الديمقراطيين
فيما قبل هل يمكن ان يكون هذا الموضوع
مختلف هذه المحاكمه مختلفه وتاثيره مختلف
على القاعده الديمقراطيه خصوصا واننا
نتحدث عن شيء يتعلق بالامن القومي
الامريكي
في حال طبعا ثبتت ادانات
انه اذا ما او هذه الاجراءات وجلسه
الاستماع هل ستكون مختلفه عن السابقاتها
ما اقوله بان اليوم نحن امام جلسه يعني
يقوم بها محامي او محقق مستقل معروف بانه
مستقل ولا يتبع لاحد من الاطراف وبالتالي
هل يمكن ان يكون وقع هذه المحاكمه مختلف
على القاعده الجمهوريه
لا اعتقد ذلك الان لا يزال الوقت مبكرا
واعتقد بان القاعده الجمهوريه لا تزال
رئيس الاسبقت تشامب والامر سيستغرقه وبعض
الوقت ومده طويله
خاصه مع راب الموعد من المحاكمه الحقيقيه
وبعدها ربما ستكون هنالك اللحظات حيث
الجمهوري حول اختياره للشامبي
بالسباق اليوم بينه وبين المرشحين الاخرين
البعض هنا يعني يتحدث عن تاثير هذه
المحاكمه اذا ما تم ادانه
يعني بحظوظ لمرشحين اخرين هل تعتقد ذلك
جزء كبير من هذه المساله هي عدد هذه
الاتهامات الموجهه ضدهم وتستمر بالزياده
القاعده الجمهوريه يبدو بانها تعتقد بانه
وزاره العدل بدات تستخدمه هذه القضايا
كسلاح ضد دانلد لانه جمهوري
ولكنني اشك جدا في اذا ما كانت هذه
القضايا سوف تزداد او
نعم
لن يبحث الناخب عن اخرين لاقصين من
الجمهوريين وربما من ذلك لكن على المدى
القصير يبدو بانهم يؤيدونه بشده وربما
قاعدته على الانتخابيه دائما سوف تؤيده هو
لديه حوالي بين 25 الى ثلاثين بالمئه من
القاعده الجمهوريه
وبالنسبه لهم مهما فعل فسوف يدعمونهم وبعد
ذلك هنالك البقيه بين السبعين الى خمسه من
القاعده او الناخبين الجمهوريين
والذين وربما سيبحثون عن مرشحين اخرين
شكرا اذا ما استمرت هذه الالتهابات شكرا
في الحملات الانتخابيه حدثنا من الولايات
المتحده
رغم كل المؤامرات السياسيه التي دبرها
خصوم ترامب ضده كما يقول هو والاتهامات
الجنائيه والفدراليه ظلت ترامب يتقدم في
استطلاعات الراي كما حصل بعد المحاكمه
الاولى قبل شهرين ترامب يتفوق على منافسيه
بفارق كبير ولائحه الاتهامات ساهمت طبعا
بتقدمه ولم تضر بالتراب وفق ما كشفته هنا
وكشفه استطلاع اجرته شبكه
وكما نشاهد مشاهدينا بالارقام كما نشاهد
هنا على الشاشه ترامب يتقدم على كل
منافسيه الجمهوريين اي اتحدث هنا عن حاكم
فلوريدا وعن سفيره الامم المتحده نكهه
الرئيس الاسبق نائب الرئيس الاسبق للتراب
في استطلاعات الراي قبل شهرين اظهرت
الارقام ان ديسنتس حصل على ما يقارب 48.
بالمئه فيما حصل ترامب على
53.8
وبالتالي تقدم ترامب على ديسنتس بعشرين
نقطه حتى الساعه اما قبل ايام وبالتزامن
مع توجيه الاتهامات الجنائيه والفدراليه
التراب فكشفت الارقام تراجعا لديسنتس
بعدما حصل على
27.2% فيما تقدم ترامب بفارق 30 نقطه
21.3% اذا كما نشاهد ايضا بان نكهه ومايك
باس لم يتقدم باي نقطه منذ اعلان ترشحهما
لسباق الرئاسه ترامب طبعا يتقدم على
الاثنين رغم كل التهديدات التي تعلق فوزه
بانتخابات الرئاسه القادمه
ما هي التهم الجديده الموجهه لترامب 37
تهمه جنائيه فيدراليه الاحتفاظ دون وجه حق
بوثائق سريه في 2021
التامر لعرقله العداله
فقال ترامب عن لائحه الاتهام وصف نفسه
بانه رجل بري وضحيه لاعتداءات سياسيه اشار
لقيام بايدن بتخزين مواد سريه
ما هي الخطوه التاليه امام ترامب يتعين
على المدعين العامين اثبات قضيتهم
بالمحكمه العمليه قد تمتد لاشهر او سنوات
قبل اصدار الحكم او التوصل للاتفاق
[موسيقى]
الاوكراني انا مليار بان قوات استعاده
قريه رابعه واقعه في اقليم دونياس جنوبي
شرقي البلاد من ايدي القوات الروسيه هذا
وكانت اعلنت استعاده ثلاث قرى وحسب
مسؤولين اوكرانيين ما زالت المعارك
العنيفه مستمره في بخموت شرقي اوكرانيا مع
التاكيد على تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه 700
متر باتجاه المدينه بحسب الاوكرانيين طبعا
هذا واوضح المسؤولون بان القوات الروسيه
قصفت مواقعهم اكثر من 200 مره بينما دمرت
القوات الاوكرانيه مركبتين قتاليتين
للقوات الروسيه
ومدفعيها هون ومستودعا للذخيره
هجوم اوكراني مضاد وان لم يكن بحجم
التوقعات الا انه بدا ياتي بثماره تدريجيا
هذا التقدم والتفوق المعاكس وفقا هنا
لصحيفه
الفرنسيه له عده اسباب ابرزها تفوق
الاسلحه الغربيه التي بحوزه الاوكرانيين
على تلك التي بيدروس ولا سيما المناظير
الليليه والاسلحه التي تعمل ليلا وتحقق
طبعا نتائج دقيقه بحسب الصحيفه وهو ما دفع
بالاوكرانيين لاتباع استراتيجيه الهجوم
ليلا لتقليل فاعليه القوات الجويه الروسيه
وتجنب الهجمات من الطائرات بدون الطيار
وفقا هنا ايضا للصحيفه الفرنسيه بدوره
معهد دراسه الحرب الامريكي اكد بان
الاوكرانيين صعدوا من هجماتهم الليليه
مستفيدين من قدرات الاسلحه الغربيه على
حساب ما يملكه طبعا الروس من اسلحه كما ان
الحلفاء الغربيين بالدبابات القتاليه
والمدرعات وايضا الاسلحه المتطوره بشكل
متزايد في الاونه الاخيره يمكن انه هو
عامل وفر مزايا استراتيجيه خطيره الاكياس
في ساحه المعركه بدورهم اشار مسؤولون في
البنداجون بان الفريق الافضل بالجيش
الاوكراني هو اللواء السابع والاربعون
الذي تم تدريبه بحسب هؤلاء في دول الناتو
وهو مجهز بمعدات وتقنيات حديثه ما قد يلعب
دورا هاما خلال الفتره المقبله بحسب طبعا
مسؤولون
تكتمت كييف على انطلاق هجومها المضاد لكن
ملامحه كانت واضحه منذ ايام
25 معركه تحدث عنها الجيش الاوكراني
بالقرب من بخمه شرقي البلاد وجنوبا بالقرب
من افديفكا ومارينكا في دونسك وقرب
بلوهوريفكا في منطقه لوغانسك وفق رويترز
ميدانيا حققت القوات الاوكرانيه مكاسب في
المرحله الاولى من الهجوم المضاده
مكاسبوا وصفاتها صحيفه وول ستريت جونل
الامريكيه بالصغيره مقارنه بحجم الاستعداد
والتسليح الغربي طيله الاشهر الماضيه
بحسب الصحيفه فان الهجمات الاولى كانت
مكلفه حيث دمرت مركبات قتال ودبابات اضافه
الى تخلي القوات الاوكرانيه عن ناقله
ومركبه قتاليه لكن ثم تتفوق لاسلحه القوات
الاوكرانيه الغربيه على الروسيه خصوصا في
الهجمات والعمليات الليليه
فالاوكرانيون اختاروا الهجوم ليلا لتقليل
فعاليات القوات الجويه الروسيه وتجنب
هجمات المسيرات وفق تقرير لصحيفه
الليبراسيون الفرنسيه غير ان المعادله
تتغير نهارا فتنكشف تحركات الاوكران
انكشاف مكن الروس من تحقيق ضربات مباشره
لدبابات ومركبات المانيه وامريكيه الصنع
استخدمتها القوات الاوكرانيه
اعترفت بذلك لكنها قللت من حجم خسائرها
خسائر دفعت بيكييف للطلب من المانيا زياده
عدد الدبابات ليوبارد الى ثلاثه اضعاف
اضافه الى مركبات قتاليه وصواريخ كروز
بعيده المدى
تستمر حتى التصريحات بين قائد قوات فاجنر
الروسيه يفجين بريكوجين ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه حيث قال بريكوجين بان على وزاره
الدفاع التركيز على وضع خطط لصد الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد بدلا من اصدار قرارات
حول القوات المتطوعه في القتال في
اوكرانيا
لنقل الصوره من خرسون ينضم الينا حذيفه
عادل مراسل العربيه حذيفه يعني اعلم ان
الظلام قد حل هناك ولكن هل يمكن رؤيه اي
شيء بحسب الصوره وراءك
مساء الخير ليان طبعا في الحقيقه لا يمكن
رؤيه شيء يعني الظلام دامس طبعا ايضا في
عمليه لترشيد الكهرباء تقوم السلطات
باطفاء الاناره في الشوارع يعني تظل
الاناره الاول الامداد فقط في المنازل
وهذا ايضا يتم ترشيده وهنالك توصيه من قبل
السلطات بعدم تشغيل الضوء الا في حالات
الحوجه الماسة داخل المنازل ذلك حتى لا
تكون هنالك اي اشارات لاستهداف المنازل او
المناطق السكنيه في داخل المدينه حيث اقف
هنا اسمع بوضوح الان الضربات الصاروخيه
المتبادله بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات
الروسيه هي ليست ببعيده من هنا براجمات
الصواريخ بالمدفعيه
بالدبابات كذلك فعمليه القصف هنا لا تهدا
ولا تتوقف خاصه في المناطق التي الان هي
يعني مغموره بالمياه دائما ما يتم اطلاق
النار في اوقات عمليات الاجلاء اليوم تم
نقل عدد من المصابين الذين تم اجلائهم
يعني مواطنين تم في اثناء عمليه الاجلاء
تم استهدافهم حذيفه انت وصلت الى المنطقه
يعني بالساعات الماضيه
يعني كيف ترصد الواقع هناك والوضع هل
نتحدث فعلا عن واقع انساني صعب جدا كيف
يتم ايصال المياه للسكان المواد الغذائيه
وحركه النزوح من هناك
هذا اكيد ليالي الوضع الانساني صعب جدا
اولا المياه تغمر 29 منطقه في اخر سون
اتحدث عن قرى عن بلدات صغيره عن ما يسمى
هنا اي تجمع سكاني صغير لا يمكن وصفه لا
ببلده ولا قريه ولكن مجموعه من البيوت في
بعض المناطق الزراعيه لذلك غمره المياه
هذه المناطق في منطقه خرسون وحده 600 متر
كيلومتر عفوا مربع تحت المياه تماما هنالك
بيوت وقرى ابتلعتها المياه بالكامل لذلك
الوضع صعب جدا هنالك مناطق لن يكون هنالك
عوده اليها في القريب العاجل حتى وان
انحسرت المياه حتى
الفيضان قل في هذه المناطق سيكون من الصعب
لان البيوت هي بيوت خشبيه في الغالب ستكون
تضررت بشكل كامل او ازينت بشكل كامل طبعا
حتى المباني الشاهقه
يعني ان يداهمنا الوقت هل يعني
تمكنت من الحديث الى السكان هناك هل ايضا
يعني تقادف الاتهامات ينسحب على السكان ام
ان معاناه فوق كل شيء
هذا صحيح تحدثت الى السكان طبعا هنالك غضب
او كبير جدا من المواطنين حول ما حدث
لمنازلهم الان هم يعيشون في المناطق تم
توفيرها لهم من قبل المتطوعين او ذهب
البعض منهم الى اقاربهم التقينا بهم من
يستطيع الدخول بعد ان حسنه المياه لينظر
في اشيائها او ياخذ بعض الاغراض ان وجدت
يعني لمسنا غضب كبير جدا هم يتهمون
الاتحاد الروسي طبعا ويقولون ان هذا طبيعه
الاتحاد الروسي هم هنا عانوا كما يقولون
من الاحتلال لفتره وشاهدوا بام اعينهم كيف
تعامل الاتحاد الروسي او جيش الاتحاد
الروسي معهم لذلك هم يصدقون تماما ان جيش
الاتحاد الروسي يمكن ان يفعل اكثر من ذلك
الوضع ماساوي جدا المياه والغذاء يصل عن
طريق المتطوعين للاشخاص الذين رفضوا
الخروج من منازلهم هنا اتحدث عن المباني
متعدده الطوابق في بعض الشقق ظل المواطنين
في هذه المباني وهنا هذه المباني التي
المياه الان انح وصلت الى متر او متر ونصف
في القبو في الطابق الاول لكن في الطوابق
العلويه المواطنين بعض المواطنين يعيشون
فيها ولكن الكثير منهم خرج خوفا من ان
يحدث شيء للمنزل او ينهار المنزل لا يوجد
كهرباء في هذه المنطقه بالتاكيد لا يوجد
مياه في الصنابير لا يوجد غاز للطهي الوضع
صعب جدا هم يطبخون على الحطب في هذه
المناطق ولكن الاغلبيه العظمى اجلاؤها
وخرجوا من هذه المناطق وتم توفير السكن
بديل لهم او ذهبوا الى اقاربهم شكرا لك
حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه حدثتنا من
خيرسون
قال مفوضه السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف ان اي المفاوضات سلام بشان
اوكرانيا لن تحدث قبل تحديد الفائز في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه في عام
2024 واضاف بورال في تصريحات صحفيه بان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ينتظر نتائج
الانتخابات الامريكيه مشيرا الى انه لا
يجب توقع بدء مفاوضات السلام قبل ذلك
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
قصينا على راسها تقرير سويدي يؤكد ان
الدول النوويه تواصل تحديث درساناتها
النوويه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في سماء المانيا اطلقت
اهم المناورات الجويه على الاطلاق في
تاريخ حلف شمال الاطلسي الذي يمتد لاكثر
من اربعه وسبعين عاما 25 دوله من دول
الاعضاء في الناتو واخرى شريكه لها بما
فيها اليابان والسويد التي تتطلع للانضمام
للحلف تشارك في تدريبات
23 الجويه هذه التدريبات الضخمه ستضم نحو
250 طائره عسكريه وبمشاركه اكثر من عشره
الاف جندي للتركيز على تنسيق والحمايه من
الطائرات من دون طيار وصواريخ كروس طبعا
في حال تعرض مدن او مطارات او موانئ تتبع
لدول الحلف لهجمات الناتو مصمم على الدفاع
عن كل شبر من اراضيه يقول هنا قائد القوات
الجويه الالمانيه اثناء تقديمه التمرين
مشددا على ان الناتو تحالف دفاعي غير ان
الهدف الابرز من وراء هذه المناورات
الجويه هو توجيه رساله الى روسيا ومفاده
هذه الرساله ان قوي وسيبقى كذلك
[موسيقى]
حذر باحثون من ان الترسانات النوويه لعدد
من البلدان وبخاصه الصين زادت العام
الماضي بينما واصلت قوى نوويه اخرى تحديث
الادوات في سياق توترات جيو سياسيه
متصاعده وقال مدير المعهد الدولي لابحاث
السلام في استقلم بان العالم يقترب او
ربما يكون قد وصل بالفعل الى نهايه فتره
طويله من تراجع عدد الاسلحه النوويه في كل
انحاء العالم
العلاقات بين القوه العظمى في العالم
تدهورت اكثر فاكثر بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه
والبشريه تنجرف الى واحده من اخطر الفترات
النوويه في التاريخ مع ارتفاع مشاهدينا
حده الحديث عن التهديد بالنووي وسباق
التسلح يقول هنا معهد استقلم الدولي
للابحاث ولابحاث السلام وهنا لابد من
التوقف عند الدول التسع التي تمتلك اسلحه
نوويه في العالم وهي طبعا كما نشاهد هنا
الولايات المتحده وروسيا وفرنسا والصين
والهند وباكستان وكوريا الشماليه
وبريطانيا وغيرها ولكن خارج حدود هذه
الدول اين تنشر الولايات المتحده وروسيا
والصين الترسانه النوويه التابعه لها
التقديرات هنا تشير الى ان القنابل
النوويه المنشوره استراتيجيا خارج الاراضي
الامريكيه تتراوح بين 100 و 200 قنبله
نوويه في اوروبا تحديدا في المانيا
وبلجيكا وايطاليا وهولندا وتركيا اما
روسيا فاعلنت لاول مره منذ انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي بانها ستنشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
على اراضي جاراتها وحليفتها بيلاروسيا
وذلك طبعا مع ارتفاع حده الصراع في
اوكرانيا اما الصين مشاهدينا فقد عمدت
خلال السنوات الاخيره الى توسيع قدراتها
العسكريه بشكل ملحوظ طبعا مع التركيز على
التحديث الترسانه النوويه وتستعد بكين هنا
لبدء مفاعل نووي جديد تحديدا على الساحل
الصيني قرب تايوان اي على بعد
135 ميلا فقط من تايوان لحمايه امنها وفق
قولها الصين طبعا
[موسيقى]
ملف وتبادل الاسرى قد يكون الطريق الذي
يمهد يمهد احياء محادثات الاتفاق النووي
المتعرقله بين الولايات المتحده وايران
بحسب طبعا المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني فان بلاده قد تجري
تبادلا للسجناء مع الولايات المتحده قريبا
اذا ابدت واشنطن حسن النيه جاء ذلك بعد
يوم من تلميح المرشد الاعلى الايراني علي
الى امكانيه التوصل لاتفاق النووي مع
الغرب في مارس الماضي مشاهدينا قال البيت
الابيض انه لا يوجد اتفاق بشان تبادل
السجناء وان واشنطن مستمره في البحث عن
كيفيه اعاده المحتجزين بينما اتهمت
الولايات المتحده ودول غربيه ايران
باحتجاز مزدوجي الجنسيه كرهائن في
مفاوضاتها مع الدول الغربيه تعثرت الامال
هنا في اطلاق سراح السجناء الامريكيين
الايرانيين مع توقف المفاوضات بشان احياء
الاتفاق النووي في الفتره الماضيه
[موسيقى]
اكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان اي اتفاق سيتم
التوصل اليه بشان الملف النووي سيحمي
مصالح ايران ويراعي الخطوط الحمراء وقال
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني بان ايران لا تجري اي مباحثات
لابرام اتفاق النووي مؤقت او جديد او اي
تفاوض يجب وان اي تفاوض طبعا يجب ان يكون
على اساس اتفاق العام 2015 فلنستمع لمقاله
لن نقبل باتفاق مؤقت لقد تبادلنا الرسائل
مع الاطراف المتفاوضه عبر سلطنه عمان لا
نوافق على اي مفاوضات لابرام اتفاق مؤقت
يحل محل الاتفاق النووي السابق نحن نعتبر
هذه المزاعم التكهنات اعلاميه او انباء
تروج لها اطراف بدوافع سياسيه او لتعكير
مسار عمليه المفاوضات الحاليه
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور بول سالم
رئيس معهد الشرق الاوسط دكتور بول يعني مع
جزم جزم الجانب الايراني بان الاتفاق
النووي الجديد لا يمكن ان يكون مؤقت وانما
اتفاق مبني على اساس العام 2015 وبالتالي
لنتحدث عن اتفاق طويل الامد هذا الجزم من
جهه وموضوع تبادل الاسرى اليوم بظل تعرقل
هذا الجانب هل هذا يعني اننا امام
استراتيجيه اظهار حصنيه ايرانيه للجانب
الامريكي
يعني اولا امر مهمه ملفت ان يكون هناك
مباحثات قائمه بين الولايات المتحده
وايران اكانت بعمان او الدوحه او بعواصم
اخرى هذا مسار يعني مهم ان يكون موجود
التركيز يبدو الان انه حول قضايا الرهائن
ولكن لا شك ان الطرفين مهتمان بالشان
النبوي ورفع العقوبات بشكل اوسع مما قد
ترفعه اي اتفاقيه حول الرهائن لا يوجد اي
دلاله ان هناك اي تقدم بالملف النووي ولكن
يبدو ان هناك اهتمام من الطرفان راينا
اهتمام ايراني
بالتطبيع وتهدئه مع السعوديه والامارات
ويعني نرى بعض الحركه بالوقت الحاضر مع
الولايات المتحده لا شك ان ايران تحت ضغط
كبير
وربما تحسب ان الرئيس بايدن لن يكون طويلا
في البيت الابيض ربما تحسب ان هناك مصلحه
من يعني اخذ بعض الفوائد ولكن يعني اي
اتفاق مع الرئيس بايدن سيكون فقط اتفاق مع
الرئيس
الاتفاق مع الرئيس بايدن يعني تخفيف
العقوبات يعني السماح بتصدير حوالي مليون
برميل من النفط يعني الافراج عن بعض
الاموال الايرانيه وطبعا
يجب ان يكون هناك التزام بموضوع التخصيب
الا يتخطى 60% وغيره ولكن المكتسبات التي
يمكن ان تحققها ايران بهذه الفتره لماذا
يعني لا تعول عليها ولا تريد اتفاق مؤقت
برايك
يعني من الواضح انها لا تريد اتفاق فقط
لانهم ابرموا اتفاق عام 2015 واتى الرئيس
ترامب وقلب الطاوله عليهم لا يريدون ان
يذهبون في نفس الاتجاه وياتي رئيس الى
البيت الابيض عام 2025 ويقلب الطاوله مره
اخرى ولكن اصبحوا يعني يدركون بالنظام
السياسي وهي اتفاقيه يعني تتخطى المشيئه
الرئاسيه عليها ان تحظى بتلتين اكثريه
مجلس الشيوخ وبالموضوع النووي الايراني لا
مجال سياسيا للوصول الى هكذا نتيجه قد
تستفيد ايران من اتفاقيه بالمرحله التي
يحكم فيها الرئيس بايدن رفع عقوبات على
مرحله معينه رفع يعني الضبط على مجموعات
ماليه كبرى مليارات الدولارات هذه هذه
استفادات تستطيع ان تحصدها في الاشهر
القادمه بالنسبه للرئيس بايدن تحرير رهائن
هو امر شعبي
الولايات المتحده عن سائر الاحزاب
الامريكيه ولكن اي اتفاق نووي لا يحظى
بنفس الشعبيه لا بالحزب الديمقراطي ولا
بالحزب الجمهوري فهناك ربما حماسه اخف او
استعداد اخف لدى اي اداره مثل اداره بايدن
ان تقدم تنازلات في الملف النووي بينما
هناك حماسه لتحرير الرهائن لانه سياسيا
وانتخابيا هذا امر شعبي هل من مصلحه
الولايات المتحده اتفاق نووي مؤقت
وبالتالي يخفف الضغط بموضوع توجيه ضربه
يعني ان كان اسرائيليه او امريكيه على
موضوع
النووي الايراني بما انه يضبط النووي
باختصار لو سمحت
لا شك هناك مصلحه من اداره بايدن لانه
يعني
تزيح عن الامكانيات ان يكون هناك حرب
جديده في الشرق الاوسط الشرق الاوسط قبل
الانتخابات عام 2024 هذا امر يريد ان
يتفاداه الرئيس بايدن ويترك كره النار اما
خلفه او الرئيس بايدن
في اداره ثانيه شكرا لك دكتور بول سالم
رئيس معهد الشرق الاوسط تحدثنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث وصف وزير الصحه السودانيه
دكتور هيثم محمد في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه
النظام الصحي في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم بانه ما زال يعاني من صعوبات
كبيره خاصه المستشفيات المركزيه التي ما
زالت خارج الخدمه كما اضاف ان هناك صعوبات
في ايصال الدواء بدورها وجهها بدوري طبعا
وجه الهلال الاحمر نداء عاجلا بسبب نقص
حاد في المواد الغذائيه
ما زالت خارج الخدمه خرابه الاربعين
مستشفى اضف لذلك ما زالت هنالك بعض
الاعتداءات المتاخره تمت في الاسبوع
الماضي على مستشفى السعودي الولاده ام
درمان ومستشفى حاجه صافي وغيره هنا
المستشفيات الخدمات الصحيحه حاليا في
ولايه الخرطوم الاساسيه خدمات الطوارئ
تقدم من خلال المستشفيات الطرفيه عن
مستشفى خاصه وصفات ام درمان تعمل الطرفيه
وبعض مستشفيات جنوب الخرطوم وبعض مستشفيات
شرق النيل المستفاده المركزيه كلها لا
تعمل
الامداد يصل بصعوبه كبيره جدا بالرغم من
اجتهادات كبيره جدا من الاطباء والكوادر
المتطوعه في ايصال الامداد
[موسيقى]
مع انقطاع الطرق القوميه بين الولايات
والعاصمه الخرطوم بسبب الحرب تزدهر
التجاره الحدوديه لسد النقص في السلع
الضروريه ففي دارفور غربيه سودان تصل
يوميا عشرات سيارات الى ولايه شرق دارفور
قادمه من دوله جنوب السودان تحمل الكثير
من السلع الاساسيه توزع على عدد من مدن
الاقليم الان طريق الجنوب مخفف لونه 99%
من المواد الغذائيه 99% يعني الان معتمدين
على جنوب السودان
معتمدين على الاعتماد ذاتي وحلا لشحن
الوقود يدخل البنزين القادم لاغندا كسلعه
مؤقته هنا اضافه الى ما يصل من دوله ليبيا
لكنها واجس الخوف تسيطر على سائق الشاحنات
بسبب انعدام الامن والتفلتات
يعني من نجد اخواننا التجار واخواننا في
الغرفه التجاريه برضو يساعدونا نحن
كمواطنين في هذه المنطقه في بضائع برضو
مخزنه يعني الناس اتعمل باسعار شويه فيها
هدوء بالرغم انه صاحبي البلد فيها بضاعه
من عدم البضاعه عشان مثلا الاسعار تكون
زايده
بحث دائم هنا في اقليم دارفور يهدف الى سد
الحاجه عبر ما يتدفق من سلع الحدوديه
موارد تعول عليها السلطات المحليه وتعمل
على تغنينها واستدامتها
تظل التجاره الحدوديه باقليم دارفور هي
حلا للعديد من السلع الاساسيه في فصل
الصيف هذا لكن يظل التحدي قائما في فصل
الخريف الذي اقترب الان صالح ابو علامه
لقناته العربيه والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه
السودان
التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
ايطاليا تعلن وفاه رئيس الوزراء الاسبق
احد اكثر سياسيينها تاثيرا وشهره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الحكومه اللبنانيه تلوح
بقطع الكهرباء عن مخيمات اللاجئين تاكيد
جاء على لسان وزير الطاقه والمياه وليد
فياض الذي اكد ضروره دفع تكلفه استهلاك
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين والسوريين من
الكهرباء في البلاد وزير الطاقه اللبنانيه
المحافي تصريحاته لامكانيه قطع الكهرباء
عن المخيمات في حال عدم السداد فياض برر
ذلك الاجراء بعدم استطاعه الدوله تامين
الطاقه للمخيمات والنازحين مجانا واستعجز
في توفير الخدمه تصريحات وزير الطاقه
اثارت استياء بين اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
الذين تتفاقم ازماتهم المعيشيه حيث بلغت
نسبه الذين دون خط الفقر فوق التسعين
بالمئه بحسب ارقام الانواع فيما اعقب
اعلان فياض انتقادات واسعه وجهتها منظمات
حقوقيه وتنظيمات فلسطينيه في قطع الكهرباء
عن المخيمات اجراء غير مسؤول لا يراعي
ظروف لا شيء
كلنا لازم ندفع حق الكهرباء لانه هذه
الكهرباء اللي عم تتامن يوم عم تتامل الى
كلفه ويجب ان تغطى ان كان الانتاج او
التشغيل او التوزيع او الصيانه او
المعاشات كله هيدا لازم يتغطوا بيتغطى
بتعريف الكهرباء وطبعا مش مطلوب من
اللبنانيين انه يغطوا كلفه استهلاك
الاخوان السوريين والفلسطينيين كل واحد
بده يخطي كلفه استهلاكه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من بيروت الصحافه
جورج العاقوري ومن بيروت ايضا اسعد بشاره
الكاتب السياسي اهلا بكما سابدا معك استاذ
اسعد يعني اليوم في بيروت او في لبنان
تحديدا هناك حوالي سته ملايين مقيم سته
ملايين منهم الثلث السوريين وبالتالي
نتحدث بان تكلفه الكهرباء ربع الكلفه
اليوم هي على المخيمات على مخيمات النزوح
هل ترى مقاله وزير الطاقه هو منطقي
بالارقام
غير منطقي يعني القرار غير منطقي لانه لا
يمكن ان يحمل اللاجئ
ازمه هو ليس مسؤولا عنها في اللاجئ هو
هربه من الحرب في سوريا وهو موجود على
الاراضي اللبنانيه
وبالتالي على الامم المتحده او المجتمع
الدولي ان يساعد لبنان في سد العجز نتيجه
امداد اللاجئين بالكهرباء ولكن ليس اذا لم
يحصل ذلك لا يمكن لاي اداره لبنانيه ان
تقوم باجراء اداري بقطع الكهرباء عن
اللاجئين هذا عمل يتناقض مع
ابسط حقوق الانسان يتناقض مع قدره هؤلاء
اللاجئين على الاستمرار والحياه الكهرباء
هي كالماء وهي كالطعام وبالتالي لا يمكن
هل هذا الاجراء ان يطبق هذا باعتقادي ان
وزير الطاقه
يعلن يعني يحاول الضغط على الامم المتحده
وعلى
لسد عجز
سانتقل الى
يعني اليوم
بالنصوص القانونيه تجبر الوكالات الدوليه
على الدفع دفع تكلفه الكهرباء اتحدث هنا
عن المخيمات المنظمه
والمدرجه يعني ضمن سجلاتها ولكن هناك
العديد من المخيمات الغير قانونيه والغير
منظمه ماذا سيفعل يعني كيف ستتعاطى الدوله
مع هذا الموضوع
ولماذا يتقاعص المجتمع الدولي عن دفع
مستحقاته اليوم
اوقاتك اولا ان المخيمات المعنيه مخيمات
اللاجئين هي مخيمات محدده ومعروفه لان
هؤلاء اللاجئين مسجلون
لدى الاونروا عفوا
كفلسطينيين مسجلون لدى وكاسوريين مسجلون
ايضا لدى الامم
وبالامكان ان يتم سداد تكلفه الطاقه كما
يتم سداد فواتير الاستشفاء وكما يتم سداد
فواتير التربيه اتصور ان الامر تاخر حتى
اليوم لان ثم تتلقع كان من قبل المجتمع
الدولي
ووقعت
وتكبد المجتمع المضيف يعني اعباء ثقيله
ولم يعد بامكان لبنان اليوم في ظل انهياره
ان يتحمل اكثر اضف الى ان ضبط الامر وضع
عدادات يحد من استهلاك كما ان هناك الكثير
من المخيمات التي تعمد الى استخدام بطاقه
بشكل غير شرعي اي تعليق كما يقال في لبنان
على الشبكه ما يؤدي الى اضرار تقنيه والى
بعض يعني الاعطال وهذا الامر نحن بغنى عنه
اليوم لاننا ندرك ان لبنان
لا يعمل على تصليح الاعطال قائمه لدى شعبه
فهذا سيزيد عليه ضغوط قطاع الكهرباء
بلبنان يعاني من عجز كبير استاذ اسعد انت
المحت الى الشق السياسي من الموضوع وهو
موضوع السوريين الذين يعني لا يريدون
العوده او لا يستطيعون العوده الى سوريا
وهم شقين هم هناك من لا يريد العوده بحسب
هناك اكثر من 30% لا يريدون العوده نهائيا
الى سوريا وهناك جزء لا يستطيع العوده
بسبب طبعا بعض الاجراءات على الحدود ووضعه
والمناطق الذي موجود فيها اذا الدوله
اللبنانيه تريد انتظار الحل السياسي هذا
ما معنى نحن ننتظر الى وقت طويل جدا الحل
السياسي لا يمكن يعني انتظاره بظل العجز
الموجود بقطاع الكهرباء
انا اريد ان انوه الى ان الكهرباء في
لبنان كهرباء التي توزعها شركه كهرباء
لبنان اي الدوله اللبنانيه نتيجه العجز
والفساد والسرقات لا تتعدى ساعتين الى
ثلاث ساعات يوميا هذا كل الموضوع
فوزير الطاقه يقول هذه الثلاث ساعات يوميا
يجب ان يدفعها اللاجئون او الدول المانحه
طيب السؤال هنا هل يمكن معالجه موضوع
اللجوء السوري وهو اصبح مشكله ضخمه باجراء
اداره سواء على صعيد الكهرباء او الكلفه
او الاستشفاء او غيره هذا امر مستحيل
وبالتالي الحل النهائي هو في عودتهم
بطريقه امنه الى سوريا برعايه المجتمع
الدولي وهنا صرخه ربما اراد الوزير ان
يكون هذا القرار قرار يعني شعبوي لانه من
الصعب ان يتقبل على تطبيق هذا التهديد
ونحن نعلم بان هناك يعني محاذير سياسيه في
هذا الموضوع هي فقط للضغط على الوكالات
الدوليه للقيام بها اليوم حتى ولو نتحدث
سبب اخر هناك سبب اخر تفضل باختي باخر
وانا الوزير ينتمي الى
بطريقه الشعبويه وليست عقلانيه صحيح ايضا
ان يطلب عوده اللاجئين من
سوريا
اليوم يعني حتى ولو نتحدث عن ساعتين او
ثلاثه حل موضوع الكهرباء التي تمثل اكثر
من نصف الدين العام هو موضوع مطلوب من
المجتمع الدولي كيف يمكن المجتمع الدولي
ان يتعاطى بالزواجيه لا يساعد بسد الثغرات
من جهه ويطلب من الجانب اللبناني حله من
جهه اخرى
انا اتصور يعني علينا ان نفصل بين الامرين
بما يتعلق بمشكله ملف الطاقه والكهرباء في
لبنان والذي يشكل اكبر عبء وادى الى بشكل
يعني بشكل اساسي الانهيار الذي نعيشه
اليوم هذا يندرج ضمن الاصلاحات المطلوبه
على لبنان وهذا يندرج ضمن الملفات
الاساسيه التي تنتظر اي رئيس جمهوريه قد
ينتخب واي انطلاقه جديده لبنان ولكن بما
يتعلق تحديدا لنعد ونحدد ما يتعلق
بالسوريين والفلسطينيين على ان تهتم بكافه
شؤون فلسطينيين وعلى الامم ان تسدد
الفواتير اكان ساعه او عشر ساعات هذا لا
يجب ان يكون ذريعه انها ساعتين كي لا يسدد
مجتمع الدولي ما يتوجب عليه ولا يجب يعني
فلنضع الامر خارج اطار الصراع السياسي
ونكون واقعيين لبنان لا يحتمل ان يسدد اي
ليره عن اي شخص مقيم على ارضه فهو لا يسدد
حقوق مواطنيه يقول مثلا لبناني بحبك يا
اسواري بس مش قد ايدي الوضع اللبناني
مذهله جدا على المجتمع الدولي ان يعمد الى
احترام واقع المجتمع المضيف المجتمع
المضيف اللبناني منهك ومنهار
شكرا لكما من بيروت جورج العقوري واسعد
بشاره على وجودك ما ليلى
[موسيقى]
اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
العراقيه احمد الصحاف عقد اجتماع حكومي
دولي بشان مخيم الهول في سوريا هذا ونقلت
وكاله الانباء العراقيه عن الصحاف قوله ان
الاجتماع سيضم وزاره الخارجيه ومستشاريه
الامن القومي والبعثات والمنظمات المقيمه
في العراق وسيبحث رؤيه الحكومه بشان مخيم
الهول مشيرا الى ان انهاء مساله المخيم
اصبحت مصلحه امنيه عليا بالنسبه للعراق
واضاف الصحافه ان الحكومه تمكنت من اعاده
10 دفعات من العوائل العراقيه القادمه من
مخيم الهول الى بلادهم
[موسيقى]
توفي رئيس الوزراء الايطاليه الاسبق
والمالك السابق ايضا لفريق ميلان سيلفيا
وبيرلس كوني في مستشفى في ميلانو متاثرا
بسرطان الدم عن عمر يناهز 86 عاما ويعتبر
بالسكوني احد اكثر الرجال نفوذا في تاريخ
ايطاليا الحديث نظرا لتاثيره وتاثير
سياساته على المجتمع الايطالي وثقافته
بشكل عام
يوجه خطاب ناريا لحشد من مناصريه او يتوسط
قاده مجموعه العشرين لالتقاط صوره تذكاريه
يتبادل اطراف الحديث معبوت او يستقبل
الزعيم الليبي الراحل معمر القذافي وقد
يتلقى لكمه في حفل فتسيل الدماء من وجهه
او يعتمر خوذه لمساعده فريق القاضي يتصدر
اسمه الصحف بسبب فضائح واتهامات جنسيه
وتتم مسالته في البرلمان ويمتل امام
المحاكم هذه مشاهد من حياه من يوصف بانه
اكثر الرجال نفوذا في تاريخ ايطاليا
المعاصر سيلفيو بارلي سكوني الذي ظل
متمسكا بطموحه السياسي حتى اخر ايامه
داعيا مناصريه للاقتراع في الانتخابات
البلديه عبر شريط فيديو سجله من المستشفى
اعتذر على ازعاجكم ولكن اود تذكيركم ان
الاحد والاثنين اي بعد غد وفي اليوم الذي
يليه هناك انتخابات اداريه لرؤساء
البلديات في 700 بلده ومدينه في ايطاليا
يعتبر بيرلس كوني احد الرجال الاكثر ثراء
في بلاده يمتلك اكبر شبكه تلفزيونيه
تجاريه والعديد من الاستثمارات الاخرى دخل
معترك السياسه عام
وحكمك رئيس وزراء لتسع سنوات كان لها
التاثير الاعمق في وجه ايطاليا المعاصر
اود ان اقول ان بيرلس كوني كان له تاثير
هائل بشكل عام على الثقافه الايطاليه اي
على عقليه الناس عندما ادخل بيرلس كون
التلفزيون التجاري في بدايه الثمانينيات
كانت ايطاليا منقسمه بشكل اساسي بين
الثقافه الكاثوليكيه التقليديه والثقافه
الشيوعيه اليسريه وقد قدم بيرلس كوني نوعا
جديدا من الفكر التقدمي وقاد عمليه
التغيير نحو مجتمع مدني
وجاب بيرلس كوني في سنواته الاخيره فضائح
جنسيه واتهم فساد برئ منها وانتخب عضوا في
مجلس الشيوخ وقد احتفظ الرجل بمكانه خاصه
في قلوب ملايين الايطاليين وتحديدا مشجعي
فريق ميلان الذي امتلكه برلسكوني اللي نحو
ثلاثين عاما وحقق معه الكثير من البطولات
قبل بيعه لمستثمرين صيني
[موسيقى]
كشف طيران الرياض عن تصميم الهويه البصريه
والفئه الاولى من تصميم الخارجي لاصول
طائراته على ان يتم اعلان التصميم الثاني
في المستقبل القريب حيث تم اطلاق حفل
تدشين الهويه البصريه والكشف عن التصميم
الخارجي للطائره في مطار الرياض ليمثل
احتفال العاصمه السعوديه بالناقل الوطنيه
الجديد
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ختم التاسعه مع العناوين
عشيه مثوله امام المحكمه ترامب يشن هجوما
لاذعا على الديمقراطيين ويتهم اقصى اليسار
بمحاوله تدريب تدمير الولايات المتحده
الجيش الاوكراني يوسع رقعه هجومه المضاد
وقائد فاغنري يدعو الدفاع الروسيه للتركيز
على فض الهجوم بدلا من الانشغال بامور
اخرى
كلها لا تعمل
الامداد يصل بصعوبه كبيره جدا الصحه
السودانيه تعلن عن صعوبات في ايصال
المساعدات والهلال الاحمر يتحدث عن نقص
حاد في المواد الاغاثه
لعدم دفعهم الفواتير وزير الطاقه
اللبنانيه يهدد بقطع الكهرباء عن مخيمات
اللاجئين في بلاده
مشاهدينا التاسع انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 مع
الزملاء راويه وطاهر مساء الخير راويه
وطاهر ماذا لديكم مساء النور مساء الخير
ليان طبعا سنتحدث عن المكاسب المحققه من
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد وفعاليه
التحصينات الروسيه كذلك امريكيا مراحل
وصول ترامب الى ميامي في فلوريدا واخر
تطورات المحاكمه شكرا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات